do you guys realize that whatever you
think you're entitled to is about what
you can get do you guys get that that's
basically how it works the problem is
you don't believe that you can change
you don't think that you could be a part
of that that means that I have to take
responsibility that means that the
decisions that I've made a life have
been bad decisions
and if the decisions that I've made in
life have been bad decisions what else
could I be wrong about
most people they don't want to see that
because they don't want to question
their own beliefs
whatever you believe about life is a
rationalization
it's a rationalization they got you to
where you're at because it was suited to
however much brain power you have and
suited to whatever lanes of
opportunities that you saw opening up to
you and what's cool is that unlike the
cockroach that cannot walk backwards
them out of all of its self men you know
becomes a lion you can actually choose
to examine the choices that you made
growing up you can examine those you can
say where do my beliefs come from and
you know what else you can do
you can proactively do things to build
your brain up I've also worked with a
lot of people and I've watched as people
will ruin their [ __ ] lives to hang on
to a false belief people are addicted to
their beliefs because it provides
comfort everybody's scared and tired man
everybody's [ __ ] scared and tired
police give us comfort so people will
avoid like that feeling of being naked
that feeling of having to like you know
in Zen they call like no group overhead
no ground underfoot or whatever like
that feeling of the world doesn't have
to make sense that feeling of the world
is uncertainty right when you can be
okay with that you have the brain power
and Elayne to be okay with that
life can become pretty [ __ ] amazing
so I was always willing to shed too but
you know police that I treasure that
made me feel comfortable police that
gave me comfort at night I was willing
to go through months or years of feeling
really [ __ ] up and unsure myself to
say no that belief was just a vehicle he
served his purpose but it's a [ __ ]
vehicle where's the next paradigm
where is the next vehicle where is the
next place to go
best thing about being human being
you're not a [ __ ] species that's
stuck you're not stuck you don't have to
go through millions of years back
because human beings we embody the
characteristics of every type of animal
we do we embody that psychologically in
our persona and you can literally just
in your life recognize all the reactive
ways that you built your personality all
the reactive ways that just responding
to environmental stimulus that you build
your belief system and you can slowly
spend time on wiring it so you must buy
in for me I bought in okay I bought into
myself I bought into what I could
accomplish so motivation for me it's
easy you can build up your brain you can
try to see a more accurate vision of the
world and then as you're doing that you
can change you can go from being a
little creepy little [ __ ] cockroach
to the [ __ ] lion to the [ __ ] wall
of the Eagle stereotypes here but you
can go to that in a couple years a
couple years flat you can change you can
you can change so much people are
stunned shocked they can't believe it
you can change now what you have to
understand is that the default is
failure for example most species are
extinct
you you think in your mind that you're
gonna succeed because it's all gonna
work out now it's not all gonna work out
actually no you have to make the right
decisions in life so one such decision
an example of a decision is the decision
to learn from harsh feedback and what I
believe is that in life we tend to
always know what the right decision is I
think that that we kind of know but we
don't always have the strength to do it
you know you know then you're making the
right decision when you're making the
bad ones most people however are caught
in a cycle of mediocrity and lack in the
lack of self-control they're not pushing
themselves hard enough and it's too hard
to get the initial gravity the initial
momentum to pull out of this you guys
see that if it when you commit to the
journey you say I give my full faith
faith to the operative work to the
journey and it's put my time into matter
what
that's what I want for you realize
you're not acting it's because you
couldn't you think that you're in
control you're not your psychologist in
control your subconscious in control and
you need to tap your subconscious in the
right direction
take some all goals actually step small
goal I'm gonna stick a week in the gym
look at yourself at the end dang I
produced it maybe man stick the month in
gym I produce it small goals I'd do a
little simple approaches I'm gonna
celebrate the small victory small goal
build bigger goal that's the
motivational seaside doesn't start
overnight it comes with time you build
action for yourself you'll write
you want to let you will make a life of
your dreams a life of your choosing